today's episode is sponsored by blinkist
the app that lets you
read or listen to an entire nonfiction
book
in just 15 minutes you can try blinkist
totally free
and get 25 off a subscription when you
go to blinkist.com
david pakman i put the link right below
this video
he did it he did it this morning we've
been
warning about this for months donald
trump this morning suggested
that the 2020 presidential election be
delayed
he is doing it this is not address
rehearsal
this is happening it's not happening yet
i mean he's trying to do it
i get the authoritarian chills when i
read
the tweet donald trump tweeted this
morning
with universal mail in voting not
absentee voting which is good
2020 will be the most inaccurate and
fraudulent election
in history it will be a great
embarrassment to the united states
of america delay the election until
people can properly
securely and safely vote the president
of the united states is actually
suggesting that an election which he
might
lose by historic margins to joe biden
should be delayed postponed
the president is trying to do the thing
they said obama would do
remember 2012 and 2016 the conspiracy
right
insisted barack obama is a marxist
dictatorial authoritarian nightmare
who is going to declare martial law send
troops to cities and suspend the
election
in order to stay in power indefinitely
barack obama was never going to do any
of those things
donald trump has sent armed
paramilitaries to cities around the
united states
and donald trump has now suggested
that the presidential election be
delayed he wants to delay
an election prescribed by the
constitution this is a constitutional
issue
this is a red alert it is no surprise
that today we got the worst gdp numbers
since world war
ii and donald trump's polling continues
to implode and trump says
you know we should look at delaying the
election we have
never had anything like this it's very
attempting to say this is unprecedented
we've never seen any
we have not had anything like this my
hope
is that this backfires and trump loses
republican support
i'm right here waiting for the
republicans that call themselves
constitutional conservatives
come out and denounce this i'm waiting
for you make me proud i'm ready
this is actually closing in
on the fascistic characteristics
that they attributed to barack obama
which never existed
we cannot allow this to happen and by
the way how is it safe to open
schools and have teachers and students
there for eight hours a day
but it's not safe to go vote which
depending on where you live takes two
minutes five minutes 10 minutes 15
minutes
and it can be done by mail making that
argument irrelevant
anyway now as a side note trump says
universal mail in voting is bad but
absentee would be okay
this time around all that we're talking
about all that states have done
many states is expand absentee voting to
anybody who wants to do it
it is not some new or different system
that would be rife or open to fraud it
is not that
this is an attack on the foundation of
the country
and an attack on democracy can donald
trump do it well it's actually
not up to him the good news is uh that
it is not up to donald trump to delay
the election
if states wanted to you could delay the
elections somewhat but i think that by
mid-december the electors have to decide
who are their
uh votes going to and if you don't have
a new president elected on january 21st
again my understanding from speaking to
some constitutional experts is
trump if trump does if you don't have an
election and trump has not been
reelected
on january 20th rather he's no longer
the president and it would go to the
speaker of the house
which would be nancy pelosi which i
can't imagine donald trump wants but
this is going to be a question of do any
governors agree
is there any governor republicans only i
would assume
that will even consider saying i think
trump might be up to something that
makes sense here i think it
we should delay the election or will all
governors say
we're doing the election and that's
basically it now
in the in the coming hours every
republican that is interviewed on
corporate media should be asked
donald trump suggested delaying the
presidential election
do you think that we should do it put
every single one of them on the record
watch some of them start to equivocate
well you know i
i didn't see the tweet i'd have to see
what it is that donald trump wants to do
uh i i can't hear you i think i think
our connection is bad
simple yes or no should we delay the
election
start putting them on record this is not
practice
this is the game this is this it's
happening right now and he is doing it
and it is absolutely horrifying i've
been warning you about today for months
july 30th the day that we knew we would
get our estimate of the second quarter
gdp number of the united states
we received that number this morning and
it is historic it's historically bad
i mean why did donald trump tweet today
that he wants to delay the election i
believe that the gdp number is part of
it
in addition to the collapsing polls the
united states economy shrank
by the biggest amount on record in the
second quarter this year
annualized second quarter gdp was down
32.9 percent
32 point the economy contracted
annualized by roughly a third in the
second quarter
now the expectation was to to be down 34
so being down 33 is like slightly less
bad than the expectation
but a historic disastrous number now
we know why it's very easy to say listen
it's not trump's fault it's coronavirus
okay but the trump administration has
failed
in terms of the coronavirus response so
the health numbers meaning cases
and deaths are worse than the numbers
had to be just look at other countries
and the economic numbers are also worse
than they had to be
the big areas of reduction in gdp were
not shockingly consumer spending in the
personal consumption category
and remember that this is just an
estimate we get more precise numbers
about another month out
so this is an estimate on july 30th
we're expecting the
sort of more more fine-tuned numbers
right around august 30th and
who knows what will be going on by then
with coronavirus now meanwhile new
jobless claims
have also gone in the wrong direction
new jobless claims
are up for the second week in a row to
1.43
million new claims this is the 19th
straight week with more than one million
people
losing their jobs of the 19 weeks
new jobless claims it was like 6.6
million that first week
uh or the second week and then they've
been declining for 15 weeks
now things have turned around and new
jobless claims have started to increase
and the unfortunate reality is that it
could get much worse
if states have to continue pulling back
if we continue to see cases rise deaths
have spiked and we'll talk about that
next
i believe states are going to have to
pull back and
the numbers are going to once again get
worse we were we were told
in april may by june 1st june 15th there
will be very few new cases and barely
any deaths
there will be a break between wave one
and what is expected to be a second wave
in the fall
we're not getting that break we are
actually when we got down to 20 000 new
cases a day
things started opening uh irresponsibly
in some states more responsibly in
others
and we are now seeing the effects of
that and the next thing i want to talk
about is the numbers
and the trajectory that these numbers
could very soon take
so let's talk about coronavirus deaths
for weeks
almost for two months the right and the
anti-science crowd
were telling us don't worry cases are up
but
deaths aren't going to go up and we
would say
why not and they would come up with
explanations like well
listen um you know it's young people now
who are getting the virus young people
don't get very sick they don't go into
the hospital they don't die
so even though cases are spiking
starting in mid-june
we're not going to see a spike in deaths
um some others would say
it's a less serious strain now the the
virus is mutated and it's far less
serious now
others said we're better at treating it
deaths won't go up we've got
you know hydroxy and redesevere
and uh we're just not going to see that
death spike because we're better at
treating it
well for the like the 10th time in the
last month
we again have set a 30 to 60 day
new high water mark in terms of deaths
and yesterday
1485 people died of coronavirus
1485. that's half a 9 11 in a single day
this is the most deaths yesterday since
may 27th or about
64 days we are quickly losing
all the progress that was made during
april
and early may we're back at the may 27th
death
number if you look at the brown line on
the graph that we have up on the screen
that's the seven day moving average so
sometimes looking at individual days
can be less than a complete picture
because we tend to get less
reporting on the weekends so if you look
at a seven day average you can see
that the seven day moving average of
deaths has been climbing since right
around the fourth of july holiday here
in the united states
that should have been a signal that
things weren't being done correctly it
has now been almost a month
since then as you probably know by now
deaths are a lagging
indicator to cases so even if we believe
that cases started to flatten on july
16th now many of us don't believe that
because that's the day on which
reporting from hospitals
shifted from going to the cdc instead
going to trump's department of health
and human services
but if you believe that cases started to
flatten
on july 16th then that means we are
still
weeks from the peak in terms of single
day deaths and that means that 10 or 14
days from now
the daily death toll could be once again
tragic it could get
to a 911 every day or
just short of it now as you know as
it's almost become uh apocryphal at this
point
but i've been saying massachusetts has
handled the virus
quite well but if you're all in the same
pool
and someone's peeing in the deep end and
you're in the shallow end
eventually you're going to get some of
that pee in the shallow end if you
understand what i'm saying eventually
it's going to reach you we're all in the
same pool and even here in massachusetts
it's a slow uptick but there's an uptick
and it started in mid-july
we had you know 175 200 cases a day for
weeks
we're now more regularly getting 300 325
cases a day and we're about to see
is it fifty thousand is it a hundred
thousand a hundred and fifty thousand
college students flying in
over the next four weeks to start
college and add to that that we're about
to get hit with the flu season in the
united states i'm seeing cvs and
walgreens advertising flu shots
i'm going to get mine very soon this
could be ramping up to
arguably the worst or most difficult
fall
in the united states from a public
health standpoint
i will just say in a very long time does
it go all the way back
uh to 1918 and the flu i'm not sure but
certainly in decades
people just aren't listening much of the
world
did handle this this was not the only
way that it could have gone the
trajectory in the united states
i hate that it has become political but
because donald trump did fail us
he has to suffer the consequences he has
to be removed
in november i don't even need a
president that will do anything that
special we just need one that will do
i was just interviewed actually on a new
zealand um
program and we'll be posting that uh
very soon to youtube and facebook
jacinda ardern in new zealand she didn't
bring any unique
medical knowledge she just realized that
she shouldn't pretend to know things she
doesn't know
she's going to defer to the doctors and
let the doctors lead the way
with her support that's all i need a
president
to do but we are now back where we were
months ago we're sort of starting from
scratch in a sense there are discussions
about needing a full lockdown reset to
get things under control
i don't think there's any political
appetite for that at this point in time
and think about all of the people who
stayed home
for months sacrificed financially
sacrificed you know psychologically and
emotionally to flatten the curve
we're back to where we were back then
and we are still up against mass
evictions growing unemployment
consider the disrespect by the way to
the health care workers
remember they're heroes we appreciate
them right well then
why isn't everybody wearing a mask how
is it respectful to health care workers
to walk around with no mask and to have
indoor dining and have casinos open in
movie theaters
we haven't done the right thing for them
as much as for the victims of the virus
it's disgusting it's tragic
and the next three months it could be
really bad
it could be really really bad uh and i
want to hear
what's going on in your state i am on
twitter at deepakman let me know how you
see it let me know what's taking place
the david pakman show at davidpakman.com
[Music]
what if you could read 10 books in just
one sitting that's exactly
what one of my favorite apps lets you do
it's called blinkist and what they do is
take
thousands of popular nonfiction books
they condense them down
into text or audio that you can consume
in 15 minutes
blinkist makes sure that you're getting
all of the
important core insights from each book
so it's perfect for exploring a book you
otherwise wouldn't have time for
if there's a full book you're thinking
about buying you can use blinkist to get
a sample
first just think how much you can enrich
yourself
by being able to soak up an entire
nonfiction book in just
15 minutes i recently read a brief
history of time of course by the great
stephen hawking this is a book that i
have been aware of for so long
and other things got in the way and it
was fantastic
to check it out on blinkist blinkist has
books on politics philosophy science
they have 27 different non-fiction
categories and a subscription is only
about eight bucks a month
and you get the entire library but
you can try it totally free and get 25
off a subscription when you go to
blinkist.com
david pakman i've put the link right
underneath this video
[Music]
the david pakman show at davidpakman.com
today's new members of the day are
arlona hadley
and carl anticell arlona and carl thank
you so much for your support
and a big thank you to charles hess
who's today's long time sustaining
member of the day
it's great to become a member it's even
better to stay a member for five years
and that's exactly
what charles has done grab a membership
at joinpacman.com
we have some tremendous discussions
happening on the david pakman show
subreddit we have more than 21 000 of
our viewers and listeners subscribed for
free
i'm selling you nothing here it's just a
place to discuss politics
davidpakman.com reddit is the place to
find it
user lefty guitarist posted a
relevant thread about how a vaccine
won't be enough to end the pandemic
and the user points out accurately that
there are many people anticipating the
vaccine
and that it will help but that social
distancing and mask wearing and avoiding
large crowds are probably going to be
necessary
for some time and there's a few reasons
why number one the vaccine does not give
you 100 immunity number two
there's going to be a ton of people that
don't get the vaccine there have been
people so
propagandized in this country to believe
that
you know bill gates wants to microchip
you with the vaccine or
whatever that there's going to be a ton
of people that just opt out so
this is absolutely correct and there's
another point much like with the polio
vaccine where there was an initial
vaccine that was not particularly
effective and over time they became more
effective
once the vaccine is out both for
production reasons and for effectiveness
reasons it's still going to be a build
to getting back to a point where we can
say
we can go back to normal so in total by
the time this is all said and done going
back to january or so which is you know
when we had our first case
we're probably talking about a two-year
period fully
fully although hopefully a lot of uh a
sort of normal day-to-day
will return in the winter or
early spring of 2021 user wagon wheel
what says
david might not be aware but trump can't
get
booed throwing out the first pitch
because there are no fans in attendance
at baseball games this baseball season
that's absolutely correct and that i
i made a mistake earlier this week when
we covered donald trump canceling
his first pitch event at the yankee
stadium
at the yankee red sox game at yankee
stadium on august 15th and it turned out
that it was never scheduled i said there
are three reasons one
trump doesn't really know how to throw a
baseball number two
trump doesn't want to get booed and
number three trump doesn't want to be
there as players kneel during the anthem
number two was wrong because there are
no fans and that i was incorrect about
that i apologize for having misled you
to the extent that i did it was
accidental
and this this viewer is completely right
join
the discussion yourself at
davidpakman.com
slash reddit we have moderators
we have standards that are applied to
the subreddit and i invite you to come
in and participate
donald trump yesterday took a fiasco
field trip to texas to brag
i guess about coronavirus and also
to brag about how he's supporting coal
and oil and fracking
all things we should actually be making
obsolete rather than trying to
do more of it was really the stuff of
nightmares i'm going to run through it i
watched it live so that you didn't have
to
although about 20 000 people did watch
it live with me on
youtube twitch and facebook but here are
some of the low lights and again this is
just a reminder
that we cannot have this in the white
house this has to be cleansed i don't
know if we can use bleach or isopropyl
to cleanse it
but we we somehow do need to remove this
now if you're watching along with me
you're going to notice in these videos
that donald trump is particularly sweaty
and extra orange it is texas after all
and i understand it was very very hot
there
uh it's become super clear to me that
psychologically these events where trump
you know will tour a factory or a
business
and then he'll rant to a hand-picked
group of sycophants these have become
sort of placeholders for the big rallies
that trump would like to be doing to
boost his ego
but he can't realistically do right now
because of the virus now donald trump
did have
one of what i would call these major
glitches where he
interrupts a word right in the middle of
the word and sort of has to reset his
brain it happened in the middle of a
word i actually can't identify maybe you
can let's take a look we are now
at the strongest point militarily
we've ever been due to talk i'll tell
you
ted where is ted he was a big leader in
the stand up again ted
these glitches have become very frequent
recently but only one such glitch during
yesterday's event
donald trump later complained that joe
biden's climate plan
is too aggressive which is like well
that's great let's let's be aggressive i
want to see that
and during this part of the rant donald
trump referred to the year 2030 which is
a milestone year for joe biden's climate
plan
he referred to it as the year 230 which
is of course a long time ago
seeking an even higher level of
restrictions
mandating net zero carbon emissions
which frankly is impossible
for all new homes offices and buildings
by 230
not possible to do and if you ever did
it
it would cost so much that your home
would be valueless
as i listen to trump rattle off what
biden wants to do
i'm reassured by it i think that's great
let's try to do it
maybe we can't but i want to be you know
trump is doing the opposite trump's
rolling back
restrictions on polluting he's rolling
back vehicle emissions
uh vehicle efficiency and emissions
standards
emissions i kind of like that portmento
uh i want a guy who maybe is going to
try to do too much and maybe we don't we
don't get there but let's try to do it
trump criticizing that donald trump also
praised texans during this
event as loving america so much that
they couldn't breathe
which is kind of weird imagery given
everything that's going on with the i
can't breathe protests and what happened
with george floyd being choked to death
let's take a look at this bizarre moment
generations of texas oil workers before
you
gave every last bit of sweat and heart
and grit
that they had to build up this country
they loved our country they loved our
country so much
they couldn't breathe donald trump also
kept accusing
joe biden uh in recent weeks of dementia
here again donald trump couldn't even
say
minneapolis very quickly just like we
did in
minneapolis and just like we will do
another place
so minneapolis ulysses
s grant talking about plasma
instead of plasma trump's having no
shortage of problems himself
and then maybe the most sort of notable
policy related claim that trump made
yesterday
is again this just ridiculous talking
point that
joe biden wants to end the suburbs but
donald trump is going to save them and
this is actually just
the dog whistle stuff we've become
accustomed to i'll explain it after we
look at the clip
that's not going to happen and by the
way i just ended the rule on
suburbs you know the suburbs we will
fight all of their lives
to get into the suburbs and have a
beautiful home there will be no more
low-income housing forced in to the
suburbs i
abandoned and took away and just
rescinded the rule
it's been going on for years i've seen
conflict for years
it's been hell for suburbia
we rescinded the rule three days ago
so enjoy your life ladies and gentlemen
enjoy your life
so this is really bad it's first of all
this
is a racially tinged dog whistle
no low-income people invading the
suburbs
is reminiscent of the black folks moving
in next door stuff of the 1950s and 60s
and prior eras
it's just complete racially tinged
red meat for his followers secondly
trump doesn't even really seem to
understand what he did he says he
rescinded a rule now what he's talking
he doesn't even know what he's talking
about but i'll tell you what he's
talking about
there's a 2015 rule the affirmatively
furthering fair housing rule okay
f a f f h and it requires
local governments if they're getting
federal funding
they have to study racial bias and
housing patterns and have a plan to
address it that's all like it's so
milk toast it's so almost nothing you if
you get money
you have to study racial bias and
housing and if you determine there is
racial bias you have to address it
that's all it does and trump is now
claiming to be some kind of hero
for rescinding it it's just racist red
meat that's all it is and trump tweeted
something similar earlier in the day
about it
widely derided as despicable saying
quote i am happy
to inform all of the people living their
suburban lifestyle dream
capitalized by the way that you will no
longer be bothered
or financially hurt by having low income
housing built in your neighborhood
your housing prices will go up based on
the market and crime will go down
i have rescinded the obama biden affh
rule enjoy this is complete
and total red meat he has now gone on to
say we should look at delaying the
presidential election
this is an ignorant delusional
narcissistic authoritarian nightmare
there's very little more to say it just
has to end in november
we've all got a vote that that we know
the solution we don't have
you know it's not like one of these
complex problems where we say
you know we've identified a problem but
figuring out
a solution is really tough we're gonna
what could we possibly
do voting starts in four and a half
weeks in some states
we're three months almost to the day a
few three months plus a few days from
the
we know what to do we have the solution
there is no greater power
than having a problem and knowing the
solution
let's now actually carry it out make
sure you're following the david pakman
show at
on instagram at david pakman show and
follow me on instagram at david.com
check out recent pictures of completely
safe socially distant beach going that i
did
shocking to many people yes i do have
legs although they are not ever visible
during the show
um follow me on instagram at
david.packman for a break from the bad
news as i like to say
the david pakman show at davidpakman.com
[Music]
the david pakman show depends on your
support and the easiest way is through
membership which includes the world
famous
bonus show as well as commercial free
audio and video streams of the show
just for members sign up today at
joinpakman.com
coupon code saves you 40 vote soon 18.
welcome back to the david pakman show
it's great to welcome back to the
program
ben burgess who's a philosophy professor
at georgia state university perimeter
college also
author of the book give them an argument
logic for the left ben has joined us
before
uh appreciate your time ben well thanks
for having me again
so i've been talking to my audience
about a concern of mine which is that
i'm seeing some who
maybe in times past had a pretty clearly
defined set of policy ideas that they
found important sometimes they'd be
socially democratic policy ideas some
are actual
socialists and i've seen
the focus on the policy sort of replaced
or preempted in some cases
by a rhetoric that we would define as
populist
and as people like federico finkelstein
for example have written about
extensively
that rhetoric often sounds very similar
on the left
and on the right and can sometimes be
used to sort of
separate uh people from a defined set of
policy ideas and sometimes in the worst
of cases
people end up supporting candidates
whose policy ideas when it comes right
down to it are really antithetical to
to where they started i let's open it
there
is this a concern that you share if so
how are you seeing it manifest if
not where where am i wrong i
know that's absolutely a concern that i
i'd share i mean i think like
populism might be most helpfully thought
of
as a rhetorical style you know there's
the people
and there's some sort of elite you know
that you're counter posing the people to
and there's nothing wrong with that
rhetorical style that's that's how
a lot of uh people that i like would
frame things you know that's that's uh
that's how bernie sanders talks
uh but it's also rhetorical style that
you could use
in service of all kinds of different
uh political agendas um you know there's
certainly lots of right-wing versions of
it
and it's it's in itself
uh that's kind of empty right that that
doesn't actually tell you much of
anything
about whether somebody is going to do
things that you'd like uh
in terms of in terms of policy whether
they're they're
even really on the same side of you as
you are in terms of policy
yeah one of the one of the sort of
corporate media
players that has really benefited from
the use of this rhetoric i think is fox
news is tucker carlson who will often
frame a lot of issues as
uh it's it's the people maybe against
corporations it's the people against
elites it's the people against whoever
but then he'll say he he'll warn you you
know make sure black lives matter
doesn't take your house or or whatever
and the solutions are very nationalistic
often xenophobic
is this new i mean it seems to me that
even if you go back to earlier 20th
century
europe there are examples of populist
rhetoric being used and it's sort of
maybe not that clear whether we're
talking about left or right populism and
it is sort of a gateway to some pretty
severe authoritarianism
yeah no i mean that could certainly be
true although i guess the point that i'd
really emphasize as far as tucker goes
is that um you know look it's
it's possible like there's nothing
that's that's impossible there's nothing
you can just rule out
about the idea that you could have
somebody
who really did have some creepy
right-wing
ideas about immigration or something
else
who really could have some degree of
redistributionism about economics
you know i think they're global examples
that i think they're historical examples
of
of that kind of thing uh but in his case
i think that like the creepy right wing
ideas about immigration are real
and the economic populism is pretty
hollow
so he does talk like that right he
he'll criticize corporations for their
lack of economic patriotism uh he'll
he'll even criticize them sometimes for
paying low wages
but then the obvious follow-up question
is okay so if the wages are too low
should we support
raising the minimum wage should we
change labor laws so it's easier for
uh people in you know amazon warehouses
to unionize
and that every other shoe never quite
drops he never really supports any of
that stuff
what's the prototypical example of what
you alluded to where where
in theory you could be sort of on the
right but still support a sort of
redistributive economic populism
who would we look to as an example of
that yeah
uh i think that there are i think
that certainly there are right wing and
even fascist parties
uh in europe that certainly support more
of that stuff than
that anybody like tucker carlson or josh
howley or any of these other
alleged american right populists
you know like the sort of you know
national front types in france places
like that that uh
you know granted uh they're operating in
a very different context where a lot of
that stuff is already just sort of part
of
the uh part of the accepted consensus
it's already happened right so of course
they're gonna
of course they're gonna support it and
on some level that might not even mean
much because you think okay
sure and like british tourists say they
support keeping the nhs
uh but they do sometimes at least
uh at least appeal uh to uh to say in
that
uh that you know that they would even
increase you know maybe certain sorts of
social spending you know if they were in
power
uh and of course who knows what they
would actually do if they're in power
but i i guess the point that i'd really
want to emphasize
is that this is something that you you
really don't get
right in the uh in the american
equivalent
of most of these people that uh that
they're really
you know it really isn't the case like
you know like like when somebody like uh
like steve bannon
talks about um anything that he wants to
do economically that would break from
republican orthodoxy
like once you really start digging into
the details right you know because some
of it
like you know he says things like
deconstruct the administrative state
that sounds sort of vaguely radical and
then
you think more about there like wait a
second do you just mean what everybody
else in your party means by deregulation
uh and small government etc
yeah right and you start to dig into
what he means and i think like
maybe it's like you know if bannon had
totally gotten his way in the trump
administration maybe
we'd be raising the top marginal tax
rate to something closer to what was
the clinton years and like spend some of
the money on infrastructure spending
but then you ask obvious like questions
about okay but like
there are tens of millions of people who
don't have health care are we gonna do
medicare for all
or are we going to um
you know eliminate tuition at public
universities
or are we going to raise the minimum
wage to 15
an hour uh and and that's not something
i ever see the bannons or the carlsons
or the hell is the world really getting
behind
can you talk a little bit about um or or
i guess maybe to frame this up
there there's some interesting
scholarship about how
there's a link between um populism
and totalitarianism and sometimes as
soon as you broach that people will say
are you saying populists are dictators
no no that's not that's not the
allegation that's being made
but can you talk a little bit about what
that link is and where the overlap
actually exists and what the limits of
that are
hmm yeah i mean i think that
uh there is a sense like
there's at least one sense which i want
to push back on this a little bit
because
uh because i think that something that
you often you often get from from
centrist certainly
uh is this way you know this sort of
habit
of demonizing
populism in general
uh and using that word maybe even as a
way
of kind of associating like good
benevolent social democrats
you know uh like like bernie sanders uh
with with people who
are right-wing populists who uh who are
more likely to have these authoritarian
tendencies
and really i mean like what i'm kind of
criticized when i say hey don't fall for
tucker carlson's alleged economic
populism
is the flip side of that right people
who say yeah these things are good
and like there's some commonality there
right that i really don't think there is
uh but but you know i i do think it's
it's it's true
that if you think that the the status
quo is very bad
uh that you do set up some sort of
opposition between the people
and some kind of hostile elite right you
know that they're that that certainly
that certainly can go in an
authoritarian direction i mean it's it
it's not
um i mean as as we're uh
as we're having this conversation donald
trump who often appeals to those things
just
floated a trial balloon on twitter about
delaying the presidential election
yes uh so so it's not like those sorts
of concerns are just coming out of
nowhere you know that they're they're
totally unfounded uh
but but i but where i would hold the
line is that i think you can
have um you can have very positive
left-wing movements that use that use
populist framing
uh that that really that really don't
have those authoritarian tendencies
and and really what i want to do uh
is is to separate these right that like
when we're just talking about populism
whether we have whether we put a plus
next to it or a minus text do it
yes uh that the danger is that we end up
conflating these things that really
don't have a lot in common with each
other
when you look at the the candidacy of
somebody like bernie sanders
as an example just just to sort of think
about it um
do do you in retrospect do you think
that
the campaign had the right balance of
rhetoric and policy do you think that
if it did that there was something in
terms of how it was received or
understood that maybe was a missing link
or or like where
where do you think that balance was when
it comes to what you would like to see
in order to keep
clear number one that there's
that the bernie populism is is as you're
pointing out
not the type that would slide into
authoritarianism as we're talking about
but at the same time that it is not
removed from a specific set of policy
ideas
yeah i mean i i think that that whatever
the you know the many problems may have
been
um you know with with that movement and
and obviously you know something went
wrong right you know because because
you know because not very many months
ago
uh the entire mainstream discussion was
about whether uh if birdie showed up at
the
democratic convention with only a
plurality of delegates you know
should he still be the nominee yeah and
uh and it turned out that that wasn't
the problem
um but uh but i certainly don't think
that being
you know light on policy detail was ever
really the the issue there i mean i
think i think there were always
you know is always very good that way
right you know uh i think that
um and certainly
you know the the kind of of of rhetoric
uh about opposing interests was was good
in in my view right i mean like you you
should
uh you should point out that this isn't
just something
that's like a sort of weird coincidence
that uh
something like medicare for all has
pulled as well as it has for as long as
it has and it's and it's so marginal
uh in in terms of its you know chances
of becoming
reality politically uh that that there
is that there are structural reasons for
this
uh that you know that makes sense to me
uh i think that i think that maybe part
of the problem
you know i don't want to let the bernie
campaign off the hook
for you know mistakes that they
undoubtedly you know undoubtedly did
you make i mean you know the proof is in
the pudding right they lost but uh
but i i also think that that part of the
reason that you do sometimes get this
confusion part of the reason you do get
people who are even like uh like bernie
trump swing voters
which you know has been exaggerated
right you know it's there are
fewer of those certainly than there were
um you know hillary mccain swing voters
in 2008
but um but it is also true that there
are people who would have voted for
ruby and you know who ended up voting
for trump and there are people who
uh there are people who who i think
would be receptive
to bernie message who who end up like
watching tucker carlson and not along
with everything that he says
and i think that the the reason for that
is
is bigger than any mistakes that that
bernie people may have made in 2016 or
2020
uh because because what bernie was
speaking to
was was this this kind of larger hunger
for um for for some kind of message that
that identified the sense that a lot of
people have
of reality you know that they that they
that the game is rigged against them
that uh that there's
uh that uh that we're not just sort of
having this neutral policy discussion
about what the you know what the best
way to go about solving these problems
is
uh that they're that uh that politics is
catering to
to the interests of a relatively small
minority of the population and many many
issues right
and and that's that's not a that's not a
sense that people have
that's that's wrong right you know
that's that's right uh
and i think that when there are so few
people who are who are really speaking
to it
uh and you know especially in a
relatively effective you know
uh compelling way that it does make some
sense
that people would be a little bit of a
cheap date about it you know that
uh that like that all it takes is tucker
carlson going on fox
and talking about how american workers
have gotten a raw deal and uh uh
and and saying some bad stuff about jeff
bezos
and you know that a lot of people can
hear that and say
hey there's this there's somebody who's
telling it like it is he must be on
their side
and then you sort of don't like if
you're
if you're happy about that right you're
happy to have that spoken to
then you sort of it's it's way too
easy to miss the fact that
when it comes to what concretely to do
about this
right other than you know um then
this kind of cruel strict enforcement of
immigration laws
uh and kind of going back to historic
republic protection of republican
protectionism right like uh
yeah pretty sure from the 1850s to the
1950s the republican party was
more protectionist than trump is now
right and nobody mistook them for
uh for for champions of ordinary people
at the expense
of american business interests uh
that like if that's that's all he's
saying or like there's a famous
there's a famous segment where where
tucker is praising
uh something elizabeth warren said about
economic patriotism
and i i and people have pointed that out
to me often you know in the course of
these discussions like hey look at
look at how uh you know there's this
some convergence between you know
between
you know the right and you know the
moderate left on this you know that he's
praising this economic statement
uh by elizabeth warren but uh but i
remember watching that
you know once you get to the end right
right the very end of it where he
actually starts talking
about policy like the only specific war
and policy items he
uh he endorses there are more
apprenticeship programs
and the government should buy america
where possible
uh which given the scale of the the
poverty
the lack of health insurance the
ridiculous wages
everything that that is the actual
discontent that he's speaking to
that's almost farcically little to
actually give people as far as
policy solutions yeah once you get to
the policy part
it completely falls apart uh we're gonna
go to a break on the
podcast tv and radio show but my full
conversation with ben will will be on
our youtube channel
the david pakman show at davidpakman.com
[Music]
the david pakman show depends on the
support of our viewers and listeners
and one way to keep us going is through
patreon
where you can pledge as little as one
dollar per month
or as much as you want at patreon.com
slash david pakman show great perks and
benefits as well
read about him
[Music]
the david pakman show at davidpakman.com
there is a three or four minute clip of
an interview that donald trump
granted to jonathan swann an axios
reporter
and it is the stuff of legend it is the
stuff of horror
it is the stuff of nightmares donald
trump saying during this interview
that not only does he read a lot but he
comprehends what he reads
what he reads really really well better
than anyone that jonathan swann has ever
interviewed
or at least recently which is quite a
statement take a look at this
i wouldn't mind if it reached my desk i
would have done something about it
it never reached my desk because do you
read your recent brief i do
i read it a lot you know i read a lot
they like to say i don't read i read a
lot
uh i comprehend extraordinarily well
probably better than anybody that you've
interviewed in a long time
uh i read a lot i spend a lot of time
with
at meetings so is there anybody in my
audience who's willing to defend trump
on this that his reading comprehension
is
is really really good by most reports
donald trump has not read
a single entire book in decades
in his entire adult life which is like
the last 50 years
i am not aware of any book that donald
trump has actually read cover to cover
people i know who have really good
reading comprehension skills
they never brag about reading
comprehension put quite simply like
anybody who has good reading
comprehension skills talks about the mat
the subject matter of what they read
rather than the fact that they're really
good at reading and understanding stuff
and this was only the tip of the iceberg
a bunch of other strange moments in this
interview and the story
really in the interview other than trump
claiming he can read well
which is a strange thing for presidents
to ever have to defend
the the real theme of this interview is
trump bending over backwards to defend
not confronting vladimir putin about
anything
take a look at trump here explaining why
he did nothing about that entire russia
russian bounty story which i continue
trying to bring up
uh did nothing about russia arming the
taliban did nothing about anything
related to russia take a look
i i have so many briefings on so many
different countries
but this one didn't reach my desk
the reason i say this is is even if you
don't believe the intel this particular
piece of intelligence and there is
dispute
no doubt there is dispute in the
intelligent community about it your
former uh john nicholson former head of
forces in afghanistan
said this is when he was working for you
that russia is supplying weapons to the
taliban
isn't that enough to challenge putin
over the killings of well we supplied
weapons when they were fighting russia
too you know when we were when they were
fighting with the taliban when
in afghanistan it's a different era well
it's a i'm just saying
so trump just erratically brings up
a completely different situation
unrelated to him
as president and putin now as president
and
their relationship this by the way
doesn't have to be anything more than
trump is enamored with putin you know
you have now
there's this slice of the left who's
getting a lot of mileage of saying oh
the russia gators the russia gators they
were crazy all
you know you don't you don't have to be
alleging anything here other than
trump we know is really impressed with
authoritarians the people he's impressed
with
are putin duterte kim jong-un
erdogan etc and there's no conspiracy
being alleged other than
trump's enamored with dictators and he
seems particularly enamored with
vladimir putin and he seems to be
finding
any way he can grasping at straws to
defend
not being tough on putin not confronting
putin that's all that this has to be you
don't have to
allege some bigger conspiracy now later
in the interview jonathan swann pushes
trump
um and insanely sort of ends up having
to explain to trump what's going on it's
very bad and it exposes trump's complete
lack of knowledge of even
basic foreign foreign policy realities
but you surely heard that right
i mean it's well known in the
intelligence army that they're arming
the taliban
russia uh i don't know when you say
arming is the taliban paying or they
give russia supplying weapons and money
to the taliban i have
heard that but it's never again
it's never reached my death i mean he
said it on the record when he was in
russia doesn't want anything to do with
afghanistan let me just say about russia
trump has access to the not that he
necessarily is taking people up on it
but trump has
access to the latest and greatest
intelligence in the world
and you can tell that he seems to be
hearing
much of what jonathan swann is bringing
up for the first time from a reporter or
at least hearing it in a way that he has
to react substantively
then trump knowing that he's flailing
and failing
tries to give jonathan swann a history
lesson and it gets really awkward
russia used to be a thing called the
soviet union
because of afghanistan they went
bankrupt they became russia just so you
do understand okay
the last thing that russia wants to do
is get too much involved with
afghanistan
they tried that once it didn't work out
how wild is that right
but but to focus on the primary topic
here
donald trump has not confronted vladimir
putin about supposed russian bounties
for taliban killing u.s troops trump
hasn't talked to him about it
and trump clearly has no interest in
talking to vladimir putin about it
despite the fact that they've now had
at least one conversation since that
story came out it's a sort of
jaw-dropping lack of self-reflection or
even
an interest in understanding
what the circumstances are and just how
bad
it looks and it's hard to fathom that
this is the president of the united
states at least for a few more months
and hopefully no longer
sort of like a sixth grader listen i
remember there were times maybe not in
sixth grade but in middle school
where i wrote a book report about a book
i didn't read okay i admitted i
there were times when i did that that's
sort of the equivalent of what donald
trump is trying to do here now the very
last thing
donald trump says it never reached his
desk that this story of alleged russian
bounties never reached his desk
that definitely seems to be a lie
there's has been
widespread and specific new york times
and other reporting
which claims that indeed donald trump
was briefed multiple times about this
and he just did nothing now i've given
you the timeline in the past
arguably as many as three or four
different times over the last year and a
half or so
where donald trump was briefed about
this new york times reported that trump
got written briefing in february of 2020
now that's just
you know five six months ago in a
presidential daily briefing trump in
this interview claims he reads it
so a sort of clever question because
jonathan swann gets trump to at least
claim he reads his pdbs
we know that this was in his pdb in
february
now cnn says that trump was briefed
somewhere in the area of march april may
on this and then associated press
sources
quote top white house officials who say
trump was made aware of this
in early 2019 a full year earlier than
the new york times and cnn say
so it's it's not just lies
it's not just being enamored with putin
it's also
either incompetence or a complete lack
of memory about the fact that he was
allegedly briefed about this multiple
times
or a sort of all-of-the-above scenario
but there's no
i mean it's you know either you care
about this stuff or you don't either
you're concerned about having an
incompetent buffoon as president or
you're not
tens of millions of people are not and
they're going to be voting for another
four years of this in just a few months
so if we want to prevent that from being
the outcome
we know what to do there's no i don't
have to give you any kind you don't have
to understand mechanical physics or
string theory or anything to understand
what the the thing is
you've got to vote everybody's got to
vote that's it uh so republican
congressman louis gomert
from texas one of the wackiest and most
ignorant
members of congress out there has tested
positive for coronavirus now gohmert
has also aggressively refused to wear
masks but he believes
that some brief moment of mask wearing
may actually be what gave him the virus
i'm going to show you that video in a
moment but as a reminder
for months louis gohmert has been seen
on capitol hill
refusing to wear a mask in fact just two
days ago he was at attorney general bill
barr's hearing
and walked out of the room right behind
william barr neither wearing a mask
neither he nor william barr wearing a
mask that is
raising questions about barr's possible
exposure barr has report reportedly
tested negative
since gomer said back in june
that he didn't need to wear a mask
because he didn't have the virus
but said he would put a mask on if he
were to get infected
apparently he must have worn a mask at
some point
because here is video of louis gomer now
covered positive
saying you know it might have been
wearing a mask
that gave me the virus
i can't help but wonder if by keeping a
mask on and keeping it
in place that if i might have
put uh some germs some fire some of the
virus
onto the mask and breathed it in i don't
know but
i got it we'll see what happens from
here but the reports of my demise
are very premature the mask
gave him the virus but he doesn't really
wear masks
if you can imagine this he was actually
scheduled to have some kind of birthday
barbecue fundraiser later in august
where donors were going to be given meet
and greet access to him
that crazy fox news host former judge
janine pirro was going to be there as a
special guest
no word on what's going on with that
event no word from fox news as to
whether
janine pirro would still be part of the
event if it were going to happen
but the mask wearing has become very
very partisan
at this point there's an axios ipsos
poll
from a few weeks ago which found that
two-thirds of democrats are wearing
masks
all the time when they're outside their
homes in public whereas only about
half that number 35 percent of
republicans are wearing masks so
it is a significant partisan divide and
that plays into remember my report from
earlier this week that
what has forced trump or pushed trump to
change his tone on coronavirus has been
that advisers went to him and said you
know
it's disproportionately our people
that's the word they used our people who
are getting this so it might be
bad from an election standpoint if this
continues now a few other things to show
you on this louis gomer went on sean
hannity's fox news program last night
and sean hannity was encouraging him to
take hydroxychloroquine and gomer said
yeah i'm taking it
and it was barely coherent he called it
hydrogeoxychlorine
or something like that take a look at
this you're uh
a guy at c cedar sinai that knows more
about hydroxychlorical than anybody
have you thought about any of these have
you talked to your doctor about it any
thoughts on it
for yourself yes yes i have and uh
thanks for
the discussion you've had about it you
know you've talked about
the one study that said it won't affect
it have to be withdrawn
so yeah my doctor and i are all in
and i got a text just before i came on
from my dear friend doctor that
just found out he had it and he said he
started
the dq regimen too so zinc original
madison and the hydrotoxic chlorine
and that will start uh just in the next
day or two
yep so thank you so gohmert
[Laughter]
how is this real life gohmert not only
has no idea
what he's taking he actually says that
hannity's propaganda coverage of
hydroxychloroquine
at least partially influenced his desire
to take it
and then just one more little video for
you here is republican congressman kevin
mccarthy
calling louis gohmert congressman covet
and then correcting himself you want to
be able to trace it put him out and just
as uh
congressman kovitz congressman louis
gomer says that he doesn't have any
symptoms
there could be other people like that so
what what a world what a world that we
live in that's just perfect yeah
i think going forward i should refer to
louis gomer as congressman covid
now to get serious for a second um
herman cain went to donald trump's tulsa
oklahoma rally or tulsa as some people
say
and he was then diagnosed with
coronavirus he has now died
and there is every reason to believe
that herman cain former presidential
candidate and supporter of trump
caught the virus at trump's corona rally
in tulsa oklahoma he is dead now
okay so when we talk about this
i take no pleasure in herman cain dying
of coronavirus
even as it appears he caught it at an
optional rally that donald trump did
but we've just got to be serious and
realistic here when i talk to people in
other countries
people like louis gomer and these other
[ __ ] republicans they often come up
and sometimes people in other countries
just can't even understand what's going
on like how is it even possible for
people like gomer to get elected
how is it even real life that donald
trump is holding
a rally with 6 500 people indoors
in tulsa oklahoma which now as far as we
believe
led to the infection of herman cain and
subsequently the death like did trump
kill his friend by having that rally is
that is that a crazy thing to say
how is it even possible that louis gomer
is elected and
you really just have to understand the
united states to understand that i mean
understand the electorate in the texas
first congressional district
these are not ad hominems the texas
first congressional district where louis
gomer
is elected and the the district that he
represents
it's wildly right-wing trump got 72
percent of the vote in the first
district of texas in 2016.
mitt romney got 72 percent of the vote
in 2012.
mccain got 69 percent in 2008.
bush got 68 and 69 percent in 2000 and
2004.
this is a wildly right wing area and
that
correlates at this point in time 2020 in
the united states
disproportionately with anti-science
beliefs
texas first district has even more
pronounced
texas problems texas is not a place with
particularly good health care
texas is not a place with particularly
good education it's
extra not good in the first district of
texas so
this is a complicated place they
tragically keep electing louis gomer
and we're seeing the consequences of
this anti-science ideology one of the
things i'm going to talk about at the
start of tomorrow's program
is that dr anthony fauci is now in the
unenviable position of having to beg and
plead with america to listen to science
and doctors
that's where we are meanwhile look at
what's happening in
new zealand look at what's happened in
south korea look at vietnam look at
you know greece place dramatically
different places culturally
geographically and economically all have
figured out
how to deal with the virus and this is
what we're dealing with it this is a
tragedy and
you know the human death the human toll
party aside is my priority i don't want
anyone to get the virus or die
but there is one side that
has been the cause of these problems and
they must be held accountable if they
are not
what's to prevent them from doing
exactly the same thing next time
we have a voicemail number that number
is 2192 david p
here's a voicemail about whatever
happened to that payroll tax cut david
calling from texas
no one's talking about
the fact that the republicans are not
doing the payroll tax cut
right now that they're not for it right
in my opinion
is because they know once joe biden is
confirmed
as president should he get the
nomination
that he is going to do the payroll tax
cut and
the blood will be on the democrats hands
i'm not so sure about that i think
republicans
are in favor of the payroll tax cut but
they recognize that there's a good
chance
nothing happens if that becomes the
sticking point i also am just not sure
that joe biden is going to do it so i
i'm interested in the way in which the
payroll tax cut stuff has imploded on
trump
but i don't know that i agree with this
particular analysis but let me know what
you think
is this caller on to something we've got
a great bonus show for you today russia
is looking to approve
a coronavirus vaccine within weeks
according to a new report
trump's looking at banning tick-tock in
the united states and we will talk about
the lack of resources for a lot of
people who want to vote by mail
what do i mean by that we will discuss
it get instant access to the bonus show
by becoming a member at joinedpakman.com
or a patron at patreon.com
davidpakmanshow
thanks so much for watching today's full
episode of the show just a reminder
today's sponsor is blinkist the
app that lets you read or listen to an
entire nonfiction book
in just 15 minutes you can try blinkist
for free
and save 25 percent off of a
subscription
when you go to blinkist.com david pakman
i've also included the link
right underneath this video